Hey guys just kind of like a massive major workout my thighs are pumped my thighs are pumped my everything's pumped up so big I can't even like I don't know I pass a mirror and I'm like wait a minute where did Sean go and it's he's right here so but who am I kidding I didn't work out I never work out I woke up this morning about the NASA thing they've seen this read this thing that the Voyager you know it's like 15 billion miles away yeah they don't quite know what's there's something going on with it where they're not receiving correct information but they're still receiving information and I'm interested in that shit did I just
lose everybody no yeah you don't you want to try to stay away from just half stories okay yeah I was gonna say I was gonna say like I'd be interested if you gave me actually anything interesting to think about okay well I can tell you what happened with my I got my MRI back for my neck this I want to know about okay okay and would they say it's a I got a better story okay so listen so this is a true story as you can notice I got my haircut yesterday right it's really really short and I got a little color in there to so Oh, Skevo, blah, blah, blah, joke, joke, joke.
Skevo, Greek, fantastic. Oh, hang on. Ba-da-ba-ba-ba-da-da-da, ba-da-ba-ba-da-ba. Is that what we do now to fucking, the fuck is going on? What are we, at a kid's birthday party? So I'm sitting there. Wait, wait, wait, you just glossed over the rinse.
You put a rinse in there, huh? What was the, what's the name of the color on that rinse? It's usually something like chestnut forever or something like that. No, that's my handle on my profile and my... On your weight is, no, it's... It's two words, chestnuts. No, it's nut on chest, right?
Please nut on chest. Dot com. Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da. We really got to get a snare drum in here. Oh, I got that, I got that swissle. Oh boy, here it comes. Here it comes, Sheki, go, Sheki.
So, listen. So wait, so I'm sitting there and you know Chris McMillan who does your hair, Jason. Sure. I'm sitting on the other side in his station across and I go, Chris, get me something like a piece of candy or something. I want some sugar or some sweet.
And he goes back and he's like, I don't have anything. You want me to make you a peanut butter sandwich? I was like, no, I don't want that. So I'm sitting there and Skevo's got my hair. And like 10 minutes later, he hands me a bag of chocolates. He sent somebody out to get me chocolate. It's full service over there. Isn't that the nicest thing in the world?
Chris did or Skevo did? Chris did. That's pretty nice. The guy who owns the salon. That's pretty nice. I know Chris. I know for Tracy. I can't believe you're asking them for snacks in there.
Why don't you just go in there and behave yourself? There wasn't a please in there. You were like, hey, Skevo, give me some candy. You said, hey, Chris, give me some candy. I know. What is going on? You're a tyrant. You're so sweet.
I can't believe that. That he actually sent somebody out to get me chocolate. Also, who eats peanut butter in a hair salon? The hair is going to get stuck in it gross. That sounds disgusting to me. Well, anyway, listen, I don't want to keep our guest waiting. I do. Okay, listen, so with all this momentum,
the hilarious momentum, let's go ahead and intro the guest. I'm super excited about her. Don't make me do it again. I'm super excited. I was just at arm's length. That is what's so weird. That little slide was like, I'd have to drive 10 miles
to buy one of those. And yours is just arm's length. I don't even know what the search terms are for it. All right, good. I'm super excited about our sweet, kind, funny, cutest pie guest today. I had the pleasure of standing next to her as we both voiced characters in that animated show
I did last year, Q-Force. And she made me laugh really hard. She's the epitome of a workaholic. She doesn't stop working. And I'm not sure why she's on smart list because she graduated valedictorian of her class from Milton Academy before attending Columbia as a lit major.
She started in films like Obvious Child and Gifted. She's guest starred on Parks and Recs and Girls and everything funny you can think of. Earlier this year, she starred with our friend, Charlie Day in the Amazon original rom-com. I want you back. And she is, of course, the star of my favorite animated character of all time, Marcel.
The shell with shoes on. It's a wonderfully talented and hysterical Jenny Slate. Jenny Slate. Who's really great. Jenny Slate. Hi, Jenny. Jenny, thanks for being here. This is so cool.
Oh my gosh, it's so, I don't know if your guests say this a lot, but like the energy mounting waiting to be revealed. And then I'll like, it depends on what your personality is. But if you're like, oh my gosh, what if I'm like a bad surprise and no one cares or, and then you guys are so funny. And I was laughing and I didn't trust the mute. I was like, maybe, like maybe I'll laugh so hard. I'll bust through the mute.
As the youngest of five children, I'm a bad surprise. So. Oh, here it is. Oh, don't show it. My name, my name, my name, my name, my name, my name, my name. You know what, Jenny? I'm so sorry. First of all, hi.
Nice to meet you. Hi. You've never met. You get to do the Lego Batman movie together. Oh, wait. We've met briefly. Yeah, but we didn't record. I think we briefly in passing, but this is our first conversation.
We've never had an actual dialogue. So, yeah. Oh, wow. Double snub before double snub. What about no chatting at the craft service table? Did you guys not? They didn't have one. Sean, tell Tracy what a craft service table is.
Craft service is where they feed the cast off the side, like with a line of just food on tables. It's a snack table. It's a snack table for everybody. More easily said. Yeah. I read somewhere, Jenny, that you are like, because I'm looking at where you are right now that you're like.
I'm not in my home. That's what I was going to say. OK, so that's what I was going to say. Listener, it looks like she's in a supply closet. She's running a travel agent to see what's going on. Yeah? I'm in a supply closet. OK, look, I'm in a supply closet that.
It looks like you got last night's dress hanging on a hook behind you, too. There's a toilet underneath me. There's a toilet. So here it is. That's where you want it to be. Are you on a boat? Are you in the head on a boat?
Or are you just suffering from colitis right now, and you just want to stay ready? You know, I don't feel safe. I don't feel like myself, unless there's a toilet truly screwed in with what's full on plumbing into just whatever space I'm in. And I need that, but even for podcast. Directly under you.
Yeah, so I live, for most of the year, in a small town in Massachusetts by the ocean. And I live on a little peninsula. And we have Wi-Fi that is like internet that my mother-in-law put in there in the late 90s, I want to say. And no one has ever decided to improve upon it. And so when it's raining, literally, it's like raining
today, there's not even really a breath of wind. But the internet becomes very bad. And so my husband owns the general store. So I came up here with my computer and my like power cord trailing, like a little tail. And was like, can I use it? Jenny, this is crazy. Can you, I know there's not a breath of wind.
What's the five-day outlook? I'm going to tell you what, Bill, we're going to get into the high 70s is what I heard. Now, Jenny, this sounds like an ideal life you live. Tell us slow about this peninsula. And what did you say most of the year at the general store? Does he wear an apron? Here's the thing, in ideal life, still
have the same personality that I had in LA. So I'm waiting for the adjustment to kick in for that chillness, that chillness to get. Maybe you need to move to chill, Mark. Come on. You come, hang on a second. Sean? Brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr.
So we're about keeping your safety in mind so you don't need to get too specific. Whereabouts are you in Massachusetts? Sure. I can see Martha's Vineyard from where I live. Are you in Woods Hole? I'm not in Woods Hole. I'm in what they call South Coast, Massachusetts.
And I'm from Massachusetts, and I did not know that this area existed. And my husband and I were kind of, oh yeah. Where are you from? Where are you from, Jenny? I'm from Milton, Mass. No shit, huh? Matter of fact, I used to know a kid.
No, he's from fucking, he's from Bill Ricker, but I knew this other kid from Milton. Fucking good kid. You should see this dude. What's his name? His name's Sully, obviously. Oh yeah, everyone is. But he's from Bill Ricker, but he lives in Milton
and he works in Peabody. That's where my cousins live. They live in Peabody. Me and fucking Peabody? I'm not kidding. I'm not kidding. Do they work for the Edison? What's that, like the Edison, like the, like, Con Edison?
Yeah, the fucking power company. Yeah, it is. Yeah, you know. Like, Con Edison. Jenny Slate, how did you, so did you just stumble into this general store one day and you said, hey, handsome felon and apron? No, ding ding ding and the bells went
when she opened the door. I don't see a ring on that finger. What about we get a malt? Yeah, yeah, listen, it's not, it's not how it went. I wish that that would be really nice. That's so romantic. But in fact, I met my husband in. Online?
Well, in the Arctic. In the Arctic. Oh, really? In the Arctic. I met him in Arctic Norway. It's coming. What? I know.
It's like, it all just sounds like, you know, those people who try to have stuff to make them more interesting, but they're actually like basic. So they say stuff like this. This is a great pitch. This is a great pitch. Keep going.
So you guys meet in the Arctic, uh-huh. So she's in the Arctic. Yeah, she's in the Arctic. She's an artist. She's in the Arctic. She's there for art. But what she does find is love. By the end, you realize that love is art and art is love.
And she's standing on the end of a peninsula with a toilet underneath her. Yeah. Can I just say that we love this? We'd like to take this off the table. The kind of thing we're looking at. We'd like to take this off the table now. It's truly first time I've ever sold anything in the room.
Wait, wait, so you met in the, how did you meet in the Arctic? What were you doing in Arctic Norway? I was making a movie there. And my friend wrote the movie and her now husband is best friends with my now husband. And so they, and I was there and they invited him to come there
and like hang out with us. To Norway. Was it a setup or just a visit? Well, this, it was just a visit. I guess there wasn't a lot of pressure put on it. So you didn't know it was a possible setup. Did he know it was a possible setup? He must have to like pack your bags
and fly all the way. For what? There's this great girl here. He must have had some sort of carrot there, right? Did he know? Well, he, he lived in Amsterdam. So we didn't go that far. You know, it's not like he came from Massachusetts.
That would be like, totally. Is he from Amsterdam? No, he's from Massachusetts, but he was living in Amsterdam. No, he's originally from Mass too. What town is he from too? Oh, let's revisit this joke. We live in his childhood home. Oh, right.
Sorry, I forgot. No, no, no, it's Will's fault. It's Will's fault. No, I should let him run his course. Yeah. No. You know what? You know what, Bateman?
Fuck you. Shut the fuck up, Bateman. Oh my God. Jenny, you, the reason why I asked about your, where you're sitting right now, cause it does look like a utility closet. I am, I'm in the closet. Yeah, yeah.
Okay. Pause. Anybody? Anybody? Hang on. Oh, let me just do it in advance. Does anyone ground ball guys? Just to bank it.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. I came out of there years ago. Okay, there we go. Okay. So, but, but I went through. Have you ever seen Vaughnville? Cause Sean would love to walk you through some of the, every time on the set of Will and Grace,
they all did that to each other. Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. I read somewhere once that you were like, it's massive OCD clean freak. Cause I am a little bit of that too. I am. Yeah. Yeah, I've got a problem.
Yeah, I'm not. You do? What's it like for, what's happening for you? Like, did you have a messy childhood, Jenny or something? Sorry, Jay. Yeah, I did. I did have a messy childhood. Wait, Jenny, don't drop your voice
and get real real with us. I did. Oh, boy. I did have a messy childhood. I think that's why I did. Adjusting in my, in my jeans. I did, I did have a messy childhood. I did, I did.
I had a messy childhood and, but very clean grandmothers like tidy houses and there was just like a big obvious like, oh, I'm way less stressed out at both of my Nana's houses than in our house where it's like crazy. It's like crazy. Yeah, I'm the same way. I grew up like in a mess.
So then your OCD comes from trying to create order and cleanliness as opposed to trying to avoid germs. Yeah, I don't think I have. I mean, obviously I'm kind of like at the COVID level of afraid of germs that maybe most people are, but for me, a tidiness means like, untidiness means like an unsettled mind. And it like makes me feel crazy.
And there are like little things that, like I don't understand why you would ever leave anything open. Like why you would leave the cabinet open. I can't get that. A dishwasher, a jar, that's crazy to me. What about toothpaste tube? What about toothpaste? For me, it's more on with you
on the people who can leave a cupboard that much open. I'm like, just close it. I was just, my friend Eli. What else are you leaving open, right? What? Because if you leave those things open, what else are you leaving open? Holy shit, holy shit.
Just come real here, you guys. Hey, wait, Shawn, you're not a, first of all, Jason, the term OCD is way overused. It's not OCD, just to be clear, it's not OCD. So nice try. It's the same way that everybody says that, I don't know, we just use a lot of these terms that are just a little overused.
Sorry, man, I'll work on it. Yeah, okay, thank you. I'm a little intense today, Jenny, because my, my, my work out correct. We interrupt them right in the middle of it. What were you blasting buys and... No, just doing it, just doing a little boxing, bro. Just doing boxing.
Right on, right on. Were you winning or? I hope so, because I was up against a bag. All right, so Eli. But Eli would, he would go, when we were in Atlanta, and I'd come to the kitchen in the morning, and there'd be four glasses, some cups, and whatever stacked next to the sink.
And I'd go, and stuff open, I'd go, at least forget, I get you're not gonna put it in the dishwasher. Can you not put it at least in the sink? It is how much, it's easier. Gravity would take your hand down even further into the sink. And run some water in it.
And run some water in it. And he literally, at one point, just kind of let me go, yeah, I don't know. Wow, yeah. You got a deal on this roommate, huh? Yeah. Yeah, Scotty can't handle when there's actual, like, pieces of food in the sink too.
Like, if I just put a plate down... He has to rinse it out. Yeah, I always, I always clean the food, make sure there's no food in the sink, but I don't really put the dishes in the dishwasher. He likes to do that. He likes to do that. Oh, that's nice.
And now, a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show. Jenny, I don't know if you're like this. I like things to be orderly and stuff. And at the same time, I'm not like a, I'm not a germaphobe, but I just like things as certain to be kind of clean and sorted.
And sorted. Yeah, I like that too. I like to, like, display my kitchenware like it is sort of a useful art installation. When people, like, move the bowls around, I'm like, okay, but like, I know it's not okay to be un-chill about that, but then when sort of the people are gone,
I'll put it back. But I mostly, I'm just like, yeah, I like to, I think it's about respect. I really do. And I like how it feels to close the circle. Like, when I make dinner every night, and like, while the thing is, was just saying this to a friend, like I guess this is a big thing.
I love a clean station. And when whatever's on the stove, getting, you know, having its final, you know, moment on the stove, I do all the dishes I can. Yeah. I love it. I get that.
It feels so good to me. I get that. You know what, I'm gonna share with you guys a story that I haven't really told you before. Tuck in. Which was, I think I was kind of messy when I was younger. I went to all boys boarding school. And when I was there,
I was in seventh grade, I was 12. And hang on, it gets mildly, mildly interesting. We're gonna start at 12? Okay. And I one day, and the guy who ran the house kept telling me, you gotta clean your room, you gotta clean your room. Finally one day, I came back and my shit was everywhere. And I came back and all my shit was gone from my room.
And I go, where's my stuff? And he goes, come with me. And he'd taken all my stuff and put it in garbage bags and put it in the back of his car. And he drove me six miles away. And I had four garbage bags full of stuff. And I was a little 12, and these big bags of stuff. And he was like, put them down and he said that,
hopefully now you'll learn to clean your room. And he drove away. And so I had these four huge bags and six miles. And I thought, how am I gonna do it? So I started doing like two bags, 50 yards, go back at the other two bags, they were too big. Are you kidding me? No, I swear to God.
And at a certain point I thought like, I'm gonna fucking break, like what's gonna happen here? And I was like, you know what I gotta do? And I just opened, I started putting everything on in jackets and whatever. And I managed to get most stuff on and then just had a small bag left of stuff. Oh my God.
And I walked like a Michelin, true story. And I walked back and I came, I remember crossing the first soccer field towards my house and him seeing me way sooner than he thought he was gonna see me. And I was carrying the shit, but I was wearing everything. And I felt like a fucking king. And I was like, fuck you.
I figured it out, you dummy. And then did you just throw it all over your room again? But you know what, last lap on me, from then on I was much better. I was much better about cleaning my stuff. This was a boarding school? Yeah, this was 1982. Wow.
Wow. I remember when my dad got blasted drunk one night, which was very, very often, he came home. And the dishes weren't done. So he's really furious about that. Did he take an Uber, do you think? They took all the sturdy dishes. And we had linoleum tile on the floor and the kitchen floor.
And he put a dirty dish on every single tile so you couldn't walk on the kitchen floor. Oh, so he was a psycho too. He was a little bit of a psycho, yeah. God darn it. We've really gotta find him. For a very special Christmas episode of Smart List, that's gonna be mine.
This is a recurring theme, Jenny, just so you know. By the way, and also, sorry, Jenny, we'll get back to you in just two seconds. Oh, no. Oh, I gotta get you. Take it. Is that my dad? Jenny, could you bring the fucking bounty up to the front?
We need more fucking bounty. Got the phone, Jenny, God damn it. Jenny, get the phone. Jenny, where the fucking trash bags? Answer it, answer it. Let's see what it is. If it's an order for some milk or something. Somebody answered it.
The machine got it. Somebody answered it. I guess it. What if you answered the phone, the person said, you get off this fucking podcast right now. You shit, you got that computer, and you get off the fucking podcast with your Hollywood friends.
Yeah. So wait, Jenny, I wanna ask you, you've done a million voiceovers, like, and you're regular on Big Mouth and Bob's Burgers, right? Yeah, and the Great North, it's on Fox. And the Great North on Fox. I mean, it's so, why voices? Like, when did you learn like you could do
all of these different things with your voice? I honestly feel like I didn't know that, I didn't know this could be like an actual job that you can do a lot. And I don't know if you guys feel this way, but like, I think it is the most fun. It's so, it's like, it's challenging creatively, but it's really also really easy.
Not that I'm showing up in my PJs, but like, do you hear these ladies behind the door? It's good, it's good, it's good out, mom. No, we haven't asked, are you in the supply, are you in the supply room of the general store? Yeah, between the groceries and the books. No, are you really in the supply? Is that true?
Yeah. Oh wow. And right now it's, so it's 1.31 there. So you've got the lunch rush. So is Ben slapping together a bunch of pastrami? Sandwiches and, you know, who's number 35? Yeah. So he owns the store, but he doesn't like work here every day.
He just, he and his brother. So he has like great grandmother used to come to this store. His family has lived in this town for a really long time. And during the pandemic, he and his brother bought the store and like did a little work on it and they put a bar in here in a bookstore. And so he's kind of like, he's like the store owner. And then he comes here every day
to do like little things for the store. But there's a lovely woman named Mary Ann, who is the manager. And she is letting me be in her office. Can you still do all your voiceover work given the wifi limitations out there? I can, but sometimes it's really bad. Like I do it in the linen closet
between my bedroom and my daughter's bedroom. And I have a little baby. Yeah, she's 17 months old. Oh, congrats. Oh my God. I thought of it, that's so amazing. First of all, I thought of the name for your autobiography if you ever want one. Here we go, here we go.
Sure, let's go. Closets, because you have a lot of closets in your life. You've got to get the slide fluid out, Sean. Or just my life in closets, you know? That's really clever. Yeah, thank you. So who was the tougher transition from you from living single and having all your stuff
in an orderly way? Was it harder for you to get used to living with Ben or the 17 month old? What's been the bigger transition? Great question. That's a really good question. Take your time. It does come down to the neat freak thing.
I think it was harder with the baby, because also like Ben, you know, understands what I say. And so when I'm like, I don't like when that's like that, he doesn't just like be like, you know, like he can understand a threat when he hears one. Right, that's right. Yeah, whereas the baby just doesn't understand my threats yet.
Isn't that amazing how you cannot negotiate with something that doesn't speak your language? Like that was a big, big lesson for me. Like I can't just say, well, you're not having, you know, dessert tonight or whatever, like they don't care. You got for the first couple of years, you got to just deal with it.
Yeah. So Jason, you'd, how, what was the age that your kids finally were able to understand? I'm going golfing today. Like what was the, because for a while they just, you know what I mean? Yeah, that was, they were 12. But wait, so, so Jenny, so you have a 17 month old daughter.
Yeah. And you guys, and now you're firmly living back in Massachusetts and Ben and his brother have opened the general store and you're there and you've kind of, you're, are you done with the West Coast? Are you done with LA? Are you done with New York? Are you just like, I'm gonna, this is where,
for now in your mind, are you like, this is my life now living here? I like it here more, but we still have my house in LA on the east side, you know. On the east side. Is that what you said? Here's the thing, on the east side, on the east side in silver.
By the way, that's a Massachusetts thing to say, by the way, which is like, oh, must be nice. You know? Must be nice. Must be nice. What does Ben think about, what does Ben think about Los Angeles? He likes it a lot.
He, I mean, we had two years there before the baby was born and he was like, whoa, I can't believe you just picking like an orange off the tree and you go for hikes and it's like very chill. I mean, we don't have like a, I don't know, like a super flashy lifestyle. So I think he was like, this is vacation-y, like this is pretty vacation-y or rich it is.
And my best friends live all around us and everything, but I will say about our house in LA, like it's a beautiful, small, old house. I bought it when I was single and I was like a heavy stoner and like the refrigerator is not even in the kitchen. It's in like a tiny room off the kitchen. And at the time I was like, I was single and I was like, it's like under the Tuscan sun,
like I'm just gonna buy an old house and just live in here and have all my shirts. And like, this will be very romantic for me. And then he came, you know what I mean? Like just like, oh, my blouses. Like it's just me and my blouses and I just don't give a hoot anymore about anything. I'm just living in my old home.
And then Ben came to live with me and I was like, oh my God, it's so messy in here, all like with two people even. It's crazy. And Ben's like, where are all these shirts? And he's like, what? He never told me that he had so many blouses. We need to open a general store, yeah.
Right, totally. Just drove him to that. So anyway, so I was like, oh, I love this house. Then he came and I was like, ooh, there's kind of a lot of stuff in here now with two people. And, but I felt like it was fine. And then now with the baby
and also we got a dog during the pandemic, like a beautiful large border collie mix. That house is like, it's just really hard. It's way too small and the stairs are really loud. And... You okay, Will? Yeah, I'm fine. Take a minute, man.
Sorry, I know, throw it in your mouth at the time. Clean the microphone a little bit, I guess. I'm sorry. Jesus Christ. I'm doing my favorite, favorite, truly. I'll never have a better joke than burping. I mean, I'm sorry about that. Sorry about that, you guys.
Welcome to Barstil Sports. I know I'm done. So... So, but you guys have decided we're going to, what is your child's name? Her name is Ida, I-D-A. So you guys said let's,
we're going to raise Ida in Massachusetts. Not out here in L.A., let's, yeah. Good choice. I think so. Tell me what's happened to her. They were like, where do you want to live? And she said, I don't know. Or Ida, huh? Oh, you've got it.
Thanks. What happened to your weed addiction? Did you crack that while you were pregnant? You got rid of all that? Or are we back into... No, no, no, no, no. She doubled down when she was pregnant. What the fuck do you think?
Yeah, I went straight to meth. Yeah, I'd like to go wide with that. I'd like to go wide with that on a podcast about how I've doubled down. Nine months till the baby's here, I got to just do all the drugs. No, I... Is it legal in Massachusetts
like it is out here in California? I think it is. I think it is now. I think it is. I actually, I had like a bad moment of like, I don't know if it's possible, but I kind of think I overdosed myself on weed. You know, I've done that.
就像加州现在这样吗？我觉得是。我觉得现在是的。我觉得是的。其实，我有过一瞬间的糟糕体验，我不知道这是否可能，但我当时觉得我好像大麻摄入过量了。你知道的，我干过这事。
It was not with a joint or anything. Like I used to smoke a lot of weed and I could smoke as much as possible, I guess it seemed like, but I took a CBD gummy that my friend was like, oh, you need to activate it with a THC dropper. And she was like, but you...
那不是通过抽大麻烟什么的。就像我以前经常抽大麻，而且我猜自己当时大概能抽多少就抽多少，但我吃了一颗我朋友给的CBD软糖，她当时说，哦，你需要用THC滴管来激活它。然后她说，但你……
And it was like, cause I had like a back issue. I don't think CBD is really real, but that might be controversial either way. She was like, if you want it to work, you have to use the... Gotta kick it in. Yeah, the THC dropper. And she was like, but you smoke so much weed
而且就像是因为我有背部问题。我不觉得CBD真的有什么用，但这话可能会引起争议，无论如何。她当时说，如果你想让它起效，你就得用那个……得让它发挥作用。对，就是THC滴管。然后她说，但是你抽了那么多大麻，
that, you know, it says between one and three droppers, you should probably take three droppers. So I was like, cool, I'll take three droppers. And then... You had to call your mom. I took the three droppers. And I just, I mean, it was like, I think it was like the worst experience of my life
以至于，你知道的，上面写着一到三滴管，你大概应该吃三滴管。所以我当时想，酷，那我吃三滴管好了。然后……你不得不给你妈打电话。我吃下了那三滴管。然后我，我的意思是，这就像，我觉得这是我一生中最糟糕的经历，
during which I tried to watch the movie, Omelie and couldn't figure out what language it was in. And was just like, what is this? That movie's so good. Oh man, yeah. I'm trying to work it in to stand up now, but it's still like a little scary that this happened. You know, it's like, it's not exactly funny yet
在那期间我试着看电影《天使爱美丽》，却完全看不出来它是用什么语言说的。当时就觉得，这到底是什么？那部电影太棒了。哦天哪，对。我现在正试图把它融入到单口喜剧里，但这事发生得还是让人觉得有点吓人。你知道的，这其实还没那么好笑，
because I actually think I did almost die. And I threw up like outside of my bathroom because I like couldn't figure out how to get over the threshold. Like just crazy shit. Went to bed with all my clothes on, my boots, like some like little zipper up booties, like got in the bed that way.
因为我当时真的觉得自己差点死掉。我吐在浴室外面，因为我当时好像搞不懂怎么迈过那个门槛。简直是些疯狂的破事。穿着我所有的衣服上了床，穿着靴子，就像那种带拉链的小短靴，就那样钻进了被子里。
Text, I need to call for help, need to call for help. And then was like, it's too late Jenny, it's too late. And then I looked, it was 6.45 PM. And I was like, oh, it was just, it was so bad. And this is truly like, oh my God, I really was like watching Amélie being like, when did this movie get so fucking scary? And what language is this?
发信息说，我需要求救，需要求救。然后又觉得，太迟了珍妮，太迟了。接着我一看表，才下午6点45分。然后我就想，哦，这真的，太糟糕了。这真的就像，天哪，我当时真的在看《天使爱美丽》，心想，这部电影什么时候变得这么他妈吓人了？而且这到底是什么语言？
What is this? Like, I don't know. I used to love this and her hairstyle was so great and everything just looked crazy. But anyway, so then the next day, my friend, you know, it was Jane Levy. Do you know her? You must know.
这是什么？就像，我不知道。我以前超爱这部电影，她的发型那么棒，一切看起来都那么疯狂。但不管怎样，到了第二天，我的朋友，你知道的，那是简·列维。你认识她吗？你肯定知道。
Yeah, so she gave me the THC thing. Anyway, so she called me and she was like, I got all your texts about the patriarchy. Uh-oh. And I was like, uh-huh. And she was like, I, Jenny, I'm so sorry. It wasn't one, not one to three droppers. It was, I misspoke, it was one to three drops.
对，所以她给了我那个THC的东西。总之，她给我打电话说，我收到了你所有关于父权制的信息。噢哦。然后我说，呃-huh。她说，珍妮，我真的很抱歉。不是一到三滴管。是我说错了，是一到三滴。
And so I took like 120 times the dose. Yeah, and I like ruined my mind. And then, and I was like, I guess I'm off weed. And like a couple of months later, I thought I'll just take a little hit and try and get back in. And it was like, it went right back to where I had been that evening, so I'm just done forever.
所以我摄入了大约120倍的剂量。对，我当时感觉脑子都要毁了。然后，我说，我想我再也不碰大麻了。几个月后，我又想，我只吸一小口，试试看能不能重新开始。结果那种感觉立刻回到了那天晚上的状态，所以我彻底再也不碰了。
Yeah, I'm not gonna try it. Oh my God, so she saved you. She saved you. Yeah, in a way, she saved me. Yeah. Wow, that's so crazy. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
对，我不会去尝试的。天哪，所以她救了你。她救了你。对，某种程度上，她救了我。对。哇，太疯狂了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。
Jenny's speaking of like getting freaked out and stuff. You know, your Netflix special called Stage Fright, you know, it was so fucking great. I loved it so much. You talk, I love the way it was shot, by the way. It's so cool. But anyway, you talk about like fear and how you hate it and you love it
珍妮，说到那种吓坏了的情况之类的。你知道的，你的Netflix专场叫《舞台惊魂》，你知道的，真是他妈的太棒了。我太喜欢了。你谈到，顺便说一句，我很喜欢它的拍摄方式。太酷了。但总之，你谈到了恐惧，以及你如何讨厌它、你又如何热爱它，
and you motivates you and how people say, just be yourself. And you were like, that's the worst advice because there's a million people in my head. Yeah. How do you choose the right pick? So how do you talk about like the love and the hate of performing live? Like what is it you, what freaks you out about it?
以及它如何激励你，还有人们怎么说“做你自己就好”。而你说，那是史上最糟糕的建议，因为我脑子里有一百万个人。好吧。你该怎么做出正确的选择？所以你如何谈论现场表演带来的爱与恨？让你对它感到害怕的究竟是什么？
I like it so much, but it must be like what like adrenaline junkies are like, I guess, I mean, I don't know. But not the guy that does the free solo. I actually think that, I sound like an old woman, but that really makes me angry that he does that. There's another one. There's another one that makes him look like. There's one that he talks about the other guy.
我太喜欢它了，但这一定就像肾上腺素瘾君子们的感受吧，我猜，我是说，我不知道。但不是那个玩无绳徒手攀岩的家伙。其实我觉得，我听起来像个老太婆，但他那样做真的让我很生气。还有另一个。另一个也让他看起来像。还有一个是他谈论另外那个家伙的。
The Alpinist. The Canadian kid. Wait, what? Isn't it called The Alpinist? And that one's really sad. The Alpinist. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But man, oh man, what a documentary.
《攀岩者》。那个加拿大男孩。等等，什么？不叫《攀岩者》吗？那部真的很令人难过。《攀岩者》。对，对，对，对。但是天哪，天哪，多么棒的一部纪录片啊。
Most of them don't end with like, don't have amazing endings, you know what I mean? No, they're not like a lot of times back in the parking lot at the end. No, oh, you mean the guy who climbs the ice waterfall at night by himself with no ropes? Does it end well? Yeah, all the guy with the bears,
它们大多数的结尾都不是那种，没有令人惊叹的结局，你知道我的意思吗？不，它们不像很多时候最后又回到了停车场。不，哦，你是说那个晚上独自一人在没有绳索的情况下攀登冰瀑的家伙？结局好吗？对，还有那个跟熊在一起的家伙，
the guy who did all those cute movies of the bears. That's what I still need to say. Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Also, I got busted on not seeing the Revenant the other night by at dinner with my parents and my husband because I said that a snuggie was like that guy in the Revenant who wears a bear suit.
那个拍了所有那些关于熊的可爱电影的家伙。这就是我一直想说的。哦，对。对，对，对。还有，前几天我和我父母还有我丈夫吃晚饭时，因为我说“斗篷毯（Snuggies）就像《荒野猎人》里那个穿着熊皮衣的家伙”，结果我被当场抓包没看过《荒野猎人》。
And everyone was like, yeah, like, truly everything. Everyone was like, what are you talking about? You're talking about Leonardo DiCaprio, like the Oscar winner, the actor, the guy. That, he's not the guy, he's Leonardo DiCaprio. And he doesn't wear a bear suit. Like, I guess he gets attacked. I didn't see it, I was too afraid.
然后所有人都说，对啊，真的，所有东西。所有人都说，你在说什么？你说的是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，那个奥斯卡得主，那个演员，那个家伙。那个，他不是那个家伙，他是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。而且他没有穿熊皮衣。就像，我猜他被袭击了。我没看，我太害怕了。
It's stunning. You should just see that once. Or just watch the YouTube special on how they shot that scene. Yeah, it's amazing. That seems like out of safe distance. Oh my God. There's also a YouTube video about the guys
这片子太震撼了。你应该至少看一次。或者直接看YouTube上关于他们是怎么拍那一幕的幕后特辑。对，太棒了。那看起来像是在一个安全的距离之外。天哪。还有一段YouTube视频是关于那些家伙
getting prepared to shoot the YouTube video for the, which is amazing. That seems like a safe and up-to-date. It's mainly just in the parking lot and putting on Patagonia's and shit, but it's good. No, I need to be pretty far afield, I think, of the central experience. I don't really want it.
准备拍摄YouTube视频的幕后，太棒了。那看起来既安全又最新。主要也就是在停车场里穿穿巴塔哥尼亚（Patagonia）的衣服什么的，但也挺好。不，我觉得我需要离核心体验相当远才行。我其实并不太想要。
Wait, go back to the fear thing. Oh, well, yeah, I think the fear is that people don't like that they won't like me and that they won't think of, like, yeah, that I'll be wearing a Patagonia jacket and I'll be like. They're great jackets. They're great jackets. They're expensive.
等等，回到恐惧那个话题。哦，好吧，对，我觉得恐惧在于人们不会喜欢我，他们会觉得，比如说，对，我会穿着一件巴塔哥尼亚夹克然后表现得像。它们是很棒的夹克。它们是很棒的夹克。它们很贵。
Well, they're expensive, but if you're a size large, they're great. They're great. Sorry, I just had to put that out there. They're telling just what you need to tell, yeah. So what, so that fear of, when you're up there on stage and they're not gonna like you, if you play that out in your head,
好吧，它们很贵，但如果你穿大号（large）的，它们就很棒。它们真的很棒。抱歉，我只是不得不说出来。它们恰好说明了你想说的话，对吧。所以，当你在舞台上，而他们不会喜欢你时，那种恐惧，如果你在脑海中把这个情景演绎出来，
is it like that, oh my God, I have no place to go? I can't, I can't hide. Right, because you still do it. Yeah, I mean, it feels like a social thing. I like it, that I'm gonna have to be up here and they're all gonna see me like just like choking and floundering and being out of control and all the things that if I succeed at,
是不是就像，天哪，我无处可去？我不能，我无处可藏？没错，因为你还是这么做了。对，我的意思是，这感觉像是一场社交活动。我喜欢这种感觉，那就是我将不得不站在这里，而他们都会看着我，看着我噎住、笨拙地挣扎、失去控制，以及所有这些事情——如果我成功了，
they'll see me as a master of like, you know, the moment and like chaos and power or whatever. Not that I see it that, but I think that would be the other side of it. Not that I think I'm like the master of chaos and I'm on stage. I would imagine that you'd have to find a place of like the perfect combination
他们就会视我为掌控当下、混乱和力量等等的大师。倒不是说我把这看作……但我想这就是另一面。并不是说我认为自己在舞台上就像是混乱的主宰。我猜你必须找到一个完美的结合点，
between sort of an adversarial relationship with the audience, right? So that you feel sort of puffed up and strong, like a worthy adversary and you can defend yourself, but then also kind of be a teammate with the audience too. You wanna try to find that connection with them. I bet that's a really, that's a real challenging place for stand-ups.
介于与观众之间某种对抗性的关系，对吧？这样你才会觉得自己有点趾高气扬、充满力量，就像一个势均力敌的对手，你可以保护自己，但同时又能成为观众的队友。你想试着找到那种与他们的连接。我敢打赌，对单口喜剧演员来说，那真是一个极具挑战性的位置。
I don't think I'd ever have the spine to do it. But it's like a date. Terrifying. I think of it like a date. Like you're like, the person could do things. I actually think you don't have the balls to do it. Fine. Or the spine.
我觉得我永远没有那个胆量去这么做。但这就像是一次约会。太吓人了。我是把它当成约会来看的。就像你在想，对方可能会做出各种举动。我其实觉得你没有种去这么做。好吧。或者说没有脊梁骨。
Or the spine. No skeletal structure whatsoever. Or sac. I don't think you have the sac. I don't think you have any of the undercarriage to do it. Sorry, Jamie. So I don't have that undercarriage either. No, you do.
或者说没有脊梁骨。完全没有任何骨骼结构。或者说没有蛋蛋。我觉得你没有蛋蛋。我觉得你根本没有做这事的底气。抱歉，杰米。所以我也缺乏这种底气。不，你有。
And I am so high. You do. You do it. And it's just terrible. How often are you still getting up there and doing stand-up? Well, in LA, I was, so I usually go up at Largo
而我嗨得不行。你有。你做到了。而且这简直太糟糕了。你现在多久还会上台去说单口喜剧？嗯，在洛杉矶的时候，我通常会去Largo（剧场），
and I was trying to go like twice a week while I was there because I want to make a new special. And that's harder, obviously, like when I want to put the baby to bed and, you know, and I like it when Ben sees my sets because especially after having the baby, it's like, oh, I guess I'm just this person who like complains about like almost everything all the time.
我在那里的时候，正试图一周去个两次，因为我想弄一个新的专场。这当然更难了，比如说当我想要哄孩子睡觉的时候，你知道的，而且我喜欢本看我的表演，因为特别是在生完孩子之后，这就像是，哦，我猜我就是那种几乎对所有事情都一直在抱怨的人。
I really want him to see me as someone who other people think is like literally in the cheapest way, like popular. Like I would like him to, you know, like everything's fine, but I'm just like, that's such a good friend. I think it's such a good look, you know, up there on stage, if they're liking you, it's like, oh, right. I forgot that there's this powerful person
我真的很想让他把我当作一个被其他人认为——用最俗气的方式来说——很受欢迎的人。你知道的，我希望他能觉得，一切都很好，但我只是在想，这真是一个很好的形象，你知道的，站在舞台上，如果他们喜欢你，那就像是，哦，对了。我差点忘了这里有个充满力量的人，
and it is nice, but it's also really scary. And, but I have to do it. Do you make him the butt of any jokes? Either intentionally or unintentionally. Like when you're sharing your stuff about home and the kid and adjusting to that new life in your house, like did you back in to sort of throwing him under the bus at all?
这感觉确实很好，但也真的很吓人。不过我必须这么做。你有没有把他当成任何笑话的靶子？无论是无意还是有意的。比如当你分享关于家庭、孩子以及适应家中那种新生活的种种时，你有没有顺便把他拉出来当挡箭牌？
I used to do that on talk shows with my wife and then she straightened me out. Did you ask permission or would you just like? I didn't. And then I got my snout smacked and then I started asking for permission and then she started saying no. And then I started looking for different material.
我以前在脱口秀节目里拿我太太开过玩笑，然后她把我给纠正过来了。你是征求过许可还是就直接？我没有。然后我的鼻子挨了当头一棒，接着我开始征求许可，然后她开始拒绝。再然后我就开始寻找不同的素材了。
Sure, sure, sure. Jenny, I want to talk about, I want to leave you with Marcel the Shell because it's so good. I watched the movie last night. It's so good. Here's what I need to say. I've been a fan of Marcel the Shell, The Shoes On, forever.
当然，当然，当然。珍妮，我想谈谈，我想以《穿鞋子的贝壳马塞尔》来作为访谈的结束，因为这太棒了。我昨晚看了这部电影。太棒了。这是我必须要说的。我一直是《穿鞋子的贝壳马塞尔》的超级粉丝，很久很久了。
I know it's been like over 10 years or something like that. Right? Yeah, yeah. And I used to watch this videos all the time. And what I love about it is if you haven't seen it, all you need to know about it is in the title. It's literally Marcel the Shell and he has shoes on. And you literally play a shell named Marcel
我知道这大概有10年甚至更久了吧。对吧？对，对。我以前经常看这些视频。我最喜欢它的一点是，如果你没看过，你只需要看标题就能了解一切。它字面意思就是贝壳马塞尔，而且他穿着鞋子。而你literally（字面意义上）就是在为一只名叫马塞尔的贝壳配音，
and he, how the voice, like how the voice, why the voice? Are you sick of the voice? Tell us all things about Marcel because how did you think of him and are you kind of like done or more, more and more because I can't get enough of him. Oh, thanks, thanks, thanks for saying that. Like right, sidebar really quick. I loved when Marcel played taps from his horn,
而他，这个声音是怎么来的，这个声音为什么是这样的？你对这个声音感到厌倦了吗？跟我们讲讲关于马塞尔的一切吧，因为你是怎么构思出这个角色的？你算是已经演够了，还是想要更多更多，因为我怎么都看不够？哦，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你这么说。顺便插播一个极短的小花絮。我太喜欢马塞尔用他的号角吹出《熄灯号》的那一段了，
which was a piece of hollow spiral macaroni. And he sleeps in his bread room, which is a bedroom made out of bread, which is fantastic. Well, bless him. And when he played taps, he plays taps. That is, that's like my favorite part of the, that like sort of, it's a sad part. It's a sort of like a eulogy part.
那是一段空心的螺旋通心粉。而且他睡在他的“面包房”里，那是一个用面包做成的卧室，简直太棒了。好吧，真有他的。当他吹响《熄灯号》时，他吹了《熄灯号》。那是，那简直是我最喜欢的片段之一，那种部分，这是一个悲伤的部分。这有点像是一段悼词。
And it's so funny. And it's also terribly sad. It's a macaroni. Yeah, it's like a shofar. In my culture, we call that a shofar. Yeah, for sure. There's a lot of secret Judaism put in there. I'm not sick of the voice.
而且既好笑又极其悲伤。那是通心粉。对，就像是一个羊角号。在我的文化里，我们把那叫做羊角号。对，确实。里面融入了很多犹太文化的秘密梗。我并没有对这个声音感到厌倦。
I love doing it. It's like, it feels like a, you know, like, I don't know, like a soothing thing. I do it by myself a lot. I like it. It came up one weekend when I was like in a hotel room, sharing a hotel room with like five friends and everyone was like broke.
我很喜欢为它配音。这感觉就像是一个，你知道的，我不知道，就像是一个能让人平静下来的东西。我经常一个人自言自语。我很喜欢它。这个创意诞生在一个周末，当时我正身处一个酒店房间里，和另外五个朋友挤在一个酒店房间里，每个人都穷得叮当响。
And we were all sharing a hotel room. And like every thing you could sleep on was being used. Like the cot and the two beds and like someone on the floor, whatever, and they were just like all men. And I felt like tiny and that it was like so messy and cramped in there. And I started to talk to like sort of rib people in that voice.
我们所有人都挤在一个房间里。凡是能用来睡觉的地方全都被占用了。比如行军床、两张床，还有人睡在地板上什么的，而且他们全都是男的。我当时觉得自己像个小不点儿，里面又乱又挤。我开始用那种声音去开大家的玩笑。
And then, and then my partner at the time had like promised that he was going to make a video for a little show in Williamsburg and he hadn't done anything yet. And he was like, could I interview that voice? And like maybe there will be a character and I'll, you know, make something with it. So he interviewed me in that voice and then he made Marcel's body.
然后，然后我当时的伴侣曾答应过要在威廉斯堡的一个小演出上做一个视频，但他当时什么都没做。然后他说，我能采访一下那个声音吗？也许能创造一个角色，然后我会（你知道的）用它做点东西。所以他用那种声音采访了我，接着他做出了马塞尔的身体。
And we just like made that video. It's so cool. So is he still a part of all the stuff going forward? Yeah, Dean Fleischer Camp. He's the director and we co-wrote it together with our friend Nick Paley. And yeah, yeah, he's, he did everything. I love, there's a million one-liners,
然后我们就像这样把那个视频做出来了。太酷了。所以他现在仍然是未来所有相关内容的一部分吗？对，迪恩·弗莱舍·坎普（Dean Fleischer Camp）。他是导演，我们和我们的朋友尼克·帕利（Nick Paley）一起共同编剧的。对，对，他，他包办了一切。我喜欢，这里有一百万个精彩的俏皮话，
but you know what Marcel uses for his skis? Our men's toenails. Yeah, toenails come in hand. Tonal clippings, not the actual toenail. Full toenail. Yeah, yeah, just the clippings. Did I see a trailer for it that's coming up? Yes.
但你知道马塞尔用什么当滑雪板吗？我们男人的脚趾甲。对，脚趾甲派上用场了。是指甲剪下来的碎屑，而不是真正的脚趾甲。整个脚趾甲。对，对，只是碎屑而已。我看到这部电影即将上映的预告片了吗？是的。
Yeah, it's coming out June 24th through 824. What? And you filmed it like over a year ago, right? It took seven years to make. Wow. Jesus. Yeah, we finished it. I want to say in the winter of- You wanted it to take seven years.
对，它将在6月24日上映，824。什么？而且你们是一年多前拍完的吧？这部电影花了七年时间才制作完成。哇。天哪。对，我们完成了。我想说是在……的冬天- 你居然想让它花七年时间。
Well, cause it stopped motion and we weren't, you know, we were like fully funded by Cineridge. It's like a, it's not a studio. It's like basically like getting arts grants basically and which also gave us total. Freedom. Yeah, which is really great. And it took a long time, the film was improvised
嗯，因为它是定格动画，而且我们没有，你知道的，我们获得了Cineridge的全额资助。这就像是一个，它不是一个制片厂。这基本上就像是获得了艺术基金的资助，这也赋予了我们绝对的。自由度。对，这真的很棒。而且这花了很长时间，这部电影是在一个很长的故事大纲的基础上即兴创作的。
off of a long treatment. So we would like record, like improvise, and then Dean and Nick would go back and cull through all the audio and start to make a script off of that. And then like write things that we should say and go back into more improvising. And that process itself took about a couple years. And then you would do the stop motion.
所以我们会录音，就像即兴表演一样，然后迪恩和尼克会回去筛选所有的音频，并开始根据这些内容编写剧本。然后写下我们应该说的话，再回去进行更多的即兴创作。这个过程本身就花了大约好几年时间。然后你们才做定格动画。
Yeah, then I think the order was we locked like the audio play, like everything that Marcel and his grandmother is the only other character besides Dean played, grandmother played by Isabella Rossellini, who is incredible. Nice. And she has a beautiful voice. Yeah.
对，然后我觉得顺序是我们锁定了音频表演，就像马塞尔和他的奶奶（除了迪恩之外唯一的另一个角色，奶奶由伊莎贝拉·罗西里尼扮演，她简直不可思议）之间的所有对话。太棒了。而且她有着一副动听的嗓音。对。
And so we did, and she let us go to her farm to improvise. Like when there were scenes- Where's the farm? It's in New York. Yeah. City? Yeah, it's in this city. It's so weird cause I'm 56th street.
所以我们完成了，她让我们去她的农场进行即兴创作。比如当有某些场景时——农场在哪里？在纽约。对，城市里？对，就在这个城市。太奇怪了，因为我在56街。
It's so high. Yeah, so strange. It's just a farm and then what are they? They just raise improvisers? That's amazing. Yeah, it's called Yes and Farm. Oh my God, that's amazing. Yeah, I just love that.
太高档了。对，太诡异了。那只是一座农场，然后他们是什么人？他们专门培养即兴喜剧演员吗？这太神奇了。对，它叫“是的，而且”农场（Yes and Farm）。天哪，太棒了。对，我就是喜欢这一点。
I love that about her. Anyway, yeah, so we recorded it all and then they filmed the live action cause like Marcel is, you know, like he's in a physical house and obviously Dean is the real person that you sometimes see like his hand or him walking away. They filmed all the live action, the whole movie's worth and then they filmed the stop motion animation on that.
我太喜欢她这一面了。不管怎样，对，所以我们录完了所有的音频，然后他们拍摄了真人实景部分，因为马塞尔，你知道的，他在一个实体房子里，很显然迪恩是那个有时你会看到的真人，比如看到他的手或他走开的背影。他们拍完了所有的真人实景，整部电影的量，然后在此基础上拍摄了定格动画。
It's so good, I love it. I loved it so much. It's, please go see it if you haven't seen it. June 24th. June 24th. June 24th, yeah. This is my sister's birthday. Is that right?
太棒了，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢它了。如果你还没看的话，请一定要去看。6月24日。6月24日。6月24日，对。这是我姐姐的生日。是吗？
Happy birthday. Well, two of them cause they're twins. Oh, that's both of them then. What are both their names, well, quick. Tannis and Shanley. Good, and what about your brother? Chuck. Wow.
生日快乐。哦，是两个，因为她们是双胞胎。哦，那她们俩都是了。她们俩叫什么名字来着，快说。坦尼斯（Tannis）和香利（Shanley）。很好，那你弟弟呢？查克。哇。
Wait, why do we test me on this all the time? I know. Jenny, it's such a pleasure. Thank you for being here. I want everybody to go to the movie. Jenny. You're hilarious and a delight. Yeah, I really am.
等等，为什么你们老是拿这个来考验我？我知道。珍妮，这真是太荣幸了。谢谢你来到这里。我希望每个人都去看这部电影。珍妮。你太搞笑、太让人开心了。对，我真的是。
Gentlemen, so are you. You really are. This is really, really fun. Next time you're out in Silver Lake, come by the smart Lestudios. That'll be nice. They don't exist. Oh, they don't.
各位，你们也是。你们真的是。这真的，真的很开心。下次你们来银湖（Silver Lake）时，顺便来SmartLess工作室坐坐。那会很棒的。它们根本不存在。哦，它们不存在。
You don't have to. We're building a whole compound out there to rival, she's about to rustle in, he's a yes and ranch. Yep, yes and ranch, top of the rock. You can't miss it if you're running out of there. Top of the rock, top of the rock. She's just up there hoeing. Anyway, honey, thank you.
你不用非得来。我们正在那儿建一整片综合建筑群，准备跟伊莎贝拉·罗西里尼的那个“是的，而且”农场一较高下。没错，“是的，而且”农场，岩石之巅（Top of the Rock）。如果你从那儿跑过去，你绝不会错过。岩石之巅，岩石之巅。她就在那儿锄地呢。不管怎样，亲爱的，谢谢你。
We love you. I'm so proud of you and I'm excited for the movie. I hope it does really well. Thank you so much. Thank you, Jenny. Please say hi to Ben and Ida. Tell her I miss her. I will.
我们爱你。我为你感到骄傲，我也为这部电影感到兴奋。我希望它大卖。非常感谢。谢谢你，珍妮。请代我向本和艾达问好。告诉她我想她。我会的。
Bye, Jenny. Bye, bye, bye, Jenny. Bye. You just slam. I go now, right? Yeah, you go now. You go. I go now.
再见，珍妮。再见，再见，再见，珍妮。再见。你直接挂断就行。我现在就挂，对吧？对，你现在就挂。你挂吧。我现在就挂。
Goodbye, thank you. You go now. Bye. That's Jenny Slate, y'all. Yeah, I love her. She is great. She's a killer. She's a real killer.
再见，谢谢。你挂吧。再见。各位，这就是珍妮·斯雷特。对，我爱死她了。她太棒了。她是个杀手。她真的是个狠角色。
I know, everybody knows her voices, right? But they don't know that she probably does all of them because they're all so different. I did a small movie with her. She was on camera, not just the voice, the face, the whole acting, the whole thing. What was the movie? She's very, very good.
我知道，每个人都知道她的配音，对吧？但他们不知道她可能一个人包办了所有的声音，因为它们听起来是如此不同。我和她一起拍过一部小电影。她是真人出镜，不仅仅是配音，还有脸蛋、整个演技，方方面面。那是部什么电影？她非常非常优秀。
I believe it's called The Longest Week. It wasn't a large film, but she was in it and she was great. I really had a good time with her. She's real fun. She's super fun, cute, funny, just adorable, super talented. Oh my God, great energy, great fun. She should teach improv and voiceover stuff because she's...
我记得片名叫《最长的一周》。那不是一部大制作电影，但她在里面表现得很棒。我和她合作得非常愉快。她真的超级有趣。她超级有趣、可爱、搞笑，简直萌化了，超级有才华。天哪，能量满满，太好玩了。她应该去教即兴表演和配音之类的，因为她……
I know, it was pretty good. Well, Will, sir, are you gonna go back, work out and finish that now? No, I was just finishing up and I'm really rattled. I'm now so hungry, obviously. Well, go get something to eat. And then I gotta go meet Jason.
我知道，这真的很不错。好吧，威尔，先生，你要回去健身并完成那个了吗？不，我刚做完收尾，我现在脑子有点乱。很显然，我现在饿极了。好吧，去吃点东西吧。然后我要去见杰森。
We got a meeting. Yeah, we got a lunch meeting. Hey, so what are you gonna eat prior to your one o'clock lunch? I am fucking... What's it gonna be, though? Is it gonna be a protein shift? Are you gonna ruin all the work you've done this morning?
我们要开个会。对，我们有个午餐会。嘿，那你下午一点的午餐之前打算吃点什么？我他妈的……到底打算吃什么？会是蛋白质补充餐吗？你会把你今天早上所有的努力都毁于一旦吗？
Punch in that dumb white bag. There it is. My energy has really plummeted in the last 10 minutes. That's sugar. Yeah, no, I sugar. All right, well, why don't we let you go? Yeah, go right now. I think you're coming today.
狠狠扇那个愚蠢的白色袋子一巴掌。就是这样。在过去的10分钟里，我的精力真的直线下降。那是糖分的锅。对，没错，我摄入糖分了。好吧，那为什么不放你走呢？对，现在就去吧。我觉得你今天会来。
We're huge fans. No, oh, wait, wait, wait, and do I just slam shut? Yeah, you just slam shut. Listen, and if you're feeling... I want you to eat. I want you to just go grab something that looks like it's got a lot of carbohydrates in it and just take a big bye.
我们是超级粉丝。不，哦，等等，等等，我是不是就直接“啪”地挂断？对，你就“啪”地挂断。听着，如果你觉得……我想让你吃点东西。我想让你随便去抓点看起来含有大量碳水化合物的东西，然后狠狠咬上一大口。
Bye. Bye. I'm in, I'm in, I'm in. Smart, lost. Smart, lost. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart, lost.
再见。再见。我进来了，我进来了，我进来了。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔贾夫（Rob Armjalf）和本尼特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbaco）100%有机纯手工打造。SmartLess。
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，你可以在任何你听播客的地方收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，也可以通过在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Wondrey应用上订阅Wondrey Plus来提前收听并免除广告。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。